what do you want to do with your life
and i was like well x i i think i'm
doing it i'm making movies it goes no no
no no but what do you want to do with
your career
in terms of getting producers on board
now being an action filmmaker how hard
was that how easy so i mean i i was
lucky enough that like what i did is i
spent like a few years
uh while i was directing horror movies
producing action films uh and so what i
did is i was working within the action
realm as like a producer of one of like
30 producers on a film or you know
whatever like i was but i was on set and
i was working with uh producers and then
what happened was um
i then slotted in for like a lower
budget action movie for the first one
that i did that was the one i did with
like dmx and johnny mester be on the law
steven seagal uh and and uh that one was
my first action movie and i was able to
use the action sequences of that to show
that i could do action so that was like
my first you know attempt at action and
what i did is i cut together an action
reel which was just like the action
sequences from that as well as like some
action sequences from the horror movies
that i had done
before because you know if you take each
horror movie i do there's maybe like you
know somebody gets into like a fight in
each thing like there's little pieces
where there's some things that are
action based you cut that all together
and then i'm like hey look i can do
action um so
i didn't really get much pushback
people believed that i could do it um
based on like showing that but i was i
was blessed to be able to have that
first opportunity to do an action movie
and that was just because i slotted in
with the company after producing a few
movies for them like they're like hey
who's going to direct this action movie
can you do it and i was like oh great
and then from there i used that to to
get
action work
how do you feel about being an action
director at this stage in your career i
love it i think it's great i mean you
know obviously i'm covered in horror
tattoos like i mean like i've got like
freddy i got
chucky by the way the chucky tv show is
great you should watch it i'm super into
uh to horror movies but i i've really
enjoyed like playing in the action world
uh and i've i've just really enjoyed
making
movies that i think are are fun uh and
i've had fun doing it so i i don't
really look at it um
any different i i
if if i'm being honest i felt like i was
kind of a little burnt out in doing
horror just because like i
i didn't really know how i could do
anything new from what i had already
done i kind of touched down on like
every sub-genre of horror at that point
um and so i was like okay well let me
try something new so like i made a kids
movie which was like that animated kids
film i did with my dad and then i was
like okay well let me try action so i
started like kind of shifting genres
anyway i kind of wanted to move around
doing that and really i mean
you know it's been kind of a longer time
coming than i
than i would expect just because like
you know i remember back when i did
bethany um i was talking about how i was
wanting to kind of start to move away
from horror um and i think i even said
in one interview i was like this this is
going to be my last horror movie um
so uh but i i i eventually maybe i would
definitely go back to doing horror like
i enjoy the genre but i like being able
to have like a budget to actually do the
things i want um you know a lot of the
horror of what i experienced was
you know
finding creative ways to pull off things
that were beyond the budget and it's
it's you know we still do that but i
still am able to you know if i want to
have a car explode in the movie and it's
in the script we actually can explode a
car
um you know if it's a horror movie um i
got to figure out a way to shoot the car
explosion without it happening
at least in my experience i'm sure
people have had other experiences but i
wasn't really getting budgets in horror
and i feel like you know horror
there's like only a few companies that
are making like bigger budget horror
movies and those companies were not
hiring me so i was like okay well you
know i've done what i can at this i
gotta find a different way
in to the next level and that's what i
was i kind of
structured a plan of how to get to the
next level as a filmmaker and that was
going through action and i really have
you know i've always loved the genre
when i watched the movies when i was a
kid growing up as well as just in
general and i kind of think that uh it's
it's been like a fun journey inside of
it and how can you expand within the
action genre what are the sub-genres of
action figures well i mean you have like
action thriller you have like you know
just pure action um but for me like how
you expand is you just get bigger talent
like the bigger the talent the bigger
the budget of the movie the bigger the
names that are involved the more stuff
you can pull off inside the genre um you
know my ultimate goal is to get to a
level of doing like really expansive
thrillers that have really good cast
because then i can kind of have like
action and
and horror in something with like a
drama element but i really just kind of
more so just enjoy doing stuff that like
um
is like i like the stories on the films
that i'm making so it's just like
interesting stories as well as like
being able to work with interesting you
know people um you know i've really been
blessed to be able to work with really
cool casts
do you feel that action films there's
more room for
a script that has you know a full arc
whereas with horror
we we all pretty much know at some point
what's going to happen with each
character well no not necessarily i
think you know i think
creativity within the confines of
anything can can can exist so
it's the same with an action or horror
you can you can pretty much be as
creative as you want within that and you
can kind of you know
have different arcs and bigger arcs
within both genres i don't think it's as
um
uh
as as necessarily confined to one genre
i mean you know i know like people like
to confine things to like boxes in our
business but i i kind of like to float
outside of the box and kind of like you
know go hey what's in this one okay all
right what's in this box like i like to
move around instead of just sticking in
the specific um
area um you know and and it actually
reminds me so when i first met dmx um
dmx uh uh i was i was talking to him and
and uh you know he he he looked at me
and the very first time i'm meeting him
and he goes what do you want to do with
your life
and i was like
well x i i think i'm doing it i'm making
movies he goes no no no no but what do
you want to do with your career
and i go well
i mean
um i want to make like marvel movies or
something at some point he goes no no no
no not that not that who do you want to
be
and i said
well
i want to be like the next
stephen spielberg or robert rodriguez
and he goes well that's beautiful dog
but how about you just be the first you
i said damn
that was like our first conversation i
was like [ __ ]
he just like dropped like a massive
truth bump on me and it's okay that i
did the voice impression because he's
hurt well he had heard me do it before
he passed away i
told this story quite a bit around him
and he thought it was funny but
uh but i will say that uh you know that
that really resonated with me and stuck
with me because
um
i feel like everybody in this business
is trying to emulate somebody else
and really like you know you could take
the good parts of different things and
from other people's careers and create
your own path you know you don't have to
follow somebody else's path especially
nowadays with you know the accessibility
of cameras and stuff like that i mean
you know i made a movie on an iphone and
now i've directed you know a movie
starring bruce willis in a movie
starring mel gibson like that that can
happen
um so i think you know what people need
to do is look at stuff as as okay
not necessarily
um
a path that you follow but like an
affirmation that what your dream is is
possible and once you know your dream is
possible build your own path towards
that dream
do people say to you how did you get
your start like you're so young did you
just you just came out of film school i
said red bull and cheerios no
i'm joking
uh no
so what i what i normally what i've done
you know um as uh
people have asked me like how i got my
start and i was like you know it's
i was straight out of
film school uh i was there for like a
week in film school uh and i was out of
high school and i'd written this like
script and i was like robert rodriguez
only needed seven thousand dollars
that's all i need for my first movie and
i made that movie and it's horrible it's
unwatchable nobody should ever see it uh
but i learned from that and but you know
even before that like you know i was i
was i was a i was a kid watching movies
like i grew up watching movies i
remember i would come home from school
my dad would like watch a movie with me
and pause it and he'd ask me like you
know okay well why was the camera moving
like that like how i was shot this way
so like you know i was being asked all
these questions and you know drilled
into my mind and i you know i was i was
the kid who would get a book report and
i would make a short film about why i
didn't want to do the book report
because i was like you know this is this
is you know i remember i almost got
kicked out of school because i was
failing chemistry and my my parents were
like you know this is horrible i knew it
was serious because it was the first
time i had seen both parents in the same
room at the same time since they got
divorced and i was like oh [ __ ] what's
going on and they're like you know he's
going to flunk out of chemistry and my
mom's like why would you not take
chemistry seriously and i'm like i'm
never going to need chemistry when i'm
making movies um so i feel like i have
like a one-track mind and i feel like
that's just like the thing like you know
um when i was talking to wes craven
before he passed away uh wes said
that um you know the people that make it
in this business are just the ones that
don't give up and i feel like that's
true to a degree if you have a singular
focus and you're focused on
getting your project made hell or high
water you're gonna i don't care if i've
got to make it for 500 bucks i'm gonna
go out there and make it and then the
next one i'll make for a thousand bucks
and you just keep going and going and
going those are the people that don't
give up and the people that build and
grow and can and can you know learn from
okay this is what didn't work on this
one now the next one it'll be better uh
because i i know that i made this
mistake on this one like that's those
are the people that are gonna make it
you know and i think like you know yeah
you hear about the guy who made some
short film that went to sundance and
then they got a marvel movie or this or
that and like those exist for sure um
and you know find your own path but i
think
the people that really don't give up are
the people that that will succeed
but when people say they want it so
badly whether they were
raised in la or they came from somewhere
else why do they give up
that i don't know that i don't know i
mean it's you know the the maybe maybe
you know
maybe family maybe pressures of of of
money maybe pressures of outside world i
i can't directly say why um but i can
say you know
i
for those people that are thinking of
giving up if you really really want it
bad i
i beg you not to give up because i would
like to see your movie
so when people say wow you just got your
start and now you're directing bruce
willis and mel gibson you say well i i
found that one funny because
it feels like a whirlwind and it feels
like i just got started for sure but i
also feel like i've been you know
directing i've been directing features
feature films since i was 18 years old
i'm i'm 29. uh so it's it's really
surreal to say that like i'm an 11-year
veteran before i'm 30. um but like you
know we could shave off some years
because maybe the first few were not
professional movies because i would also
say please don't watch them um
so maybe like i'd say you know it's
still it's it's it's it's a whirlwind um
you know it's it's everything
it's amazing because everything feels so
fast and yet so slow
um you know uh and i try to not focus on
um
that type of stuff and i try to just
focus on
making the best movie possible in what
i'm doing because i'm hoping that every
time i make a movie that will lead to
the next one